Are minority rights in India are under threat?
In a country known for pluralism, India’s
secularists face their biggest challenge yet.
Vigilante attacks on Muslims have shocked
many Indians.
A firebrand Hindu cleric with a thuggish private
militia now runs India’s largest state.
On social media and TV, Hindu culture warriors
promote hardline identity politics.
India’s ruling Bharatiya Janata Party bears
some of the blame for this new extremism,
but there’s also something deeper going
on.
Simply but, the model of Indian secularism
has failed.
Tiptoeing around religious sensitivities,
India let different religions implement their
own personal laws rather than have one law
for all.
This meant customs like polygamy or divorce
by decree are legal for Muslims, but not for
Christians or Hindus.
Championing group rights over individual rights,
and tolerating regressive religious practices,
bred Hindu resentment.
Indian secularists are right to worry about
a new wave of bigotry.
But to fight it they need to look forward,
not backward.
Rather than go back to a failed model that
prioritized special rights for some, they
should champion equal rights for all.
To learn more about my take on India, check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you want our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.